S
DIGNITY OF BEING TOLD OF WHAT HE
COULDN'T SAY OR WHAT HE REALLY
THOUGHT.
>> IT DROVE ME CRAZY TO NOT BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT I LIKED TRUMP.
THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S ME.
IMAGINE ME NOT BEING ABLE TO SAY
WHAT I WANTED.
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF BEING
FAMOUS?
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF HAVING
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LOVE YOUR
MUSIC?
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF HAVING A
VOICE IF YOU CAN'T EVEN USE YOUR
OWN VOICE AND CONNECT IT TO YOUR
OWN OPINIONS?
THAT'S WHERE THE DISCONNECT
HAPPENS.
THAT'S WHERE THE QUOTE, I THINK,
WRONGLY DIAGNOSED.
THAT'S WHERE THE BIPOLARITY IS.
YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING YOU ARE
THINKING, BUT YOU ARE TOLD TO
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY IT IN
PUBLIC.
WELL, I NEVER ACTUALLY TOLD
PEOPLE THAT I LIKED TRUMP WHEN
HE WAS RUNNING BECAUSE I WAS
BULLIED BY HOLLYWOOD.
BECAUSE I STAYED IN HOLLYWOOD
AND PEOPLE SAY THINK ABOUT YOUR
KIDS AND I'M TRYING TO HOLD ON
TO THE MARRIAGE.
SO I AM JUST BITING MY TONGUE.
THERE IS SO MANY FATHERS AND
MOTHERS THAT GO TO WORK EVERY
DAY AND THEY ARE IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY ARE BITING THEIR
TONGUE BECAUSE THEY THINK IT
WILL BE BETTER FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
EVEN ME IN MY POSITION, I WAS
BITING MY TONGUE ON MY POLITICAL
OPINION BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE BETTER FOR MY CHILDREN.
AND NOW YOU LOOK UP AND MY KIDS
ARE GOING TO A SCHOOL THAT
TEACHES BLACK KIDS COMPLICATED
KWANZAA.
THEY DON'T TEACH, EVEN CHRISTMAS
ITSELF.
THEY DON'T TEACH IT AT CR
CANYON.
WHAT THEY DO IS TAKE ALL THE
CELEBRITIES, THE ACTORS, THE
BASKETBALL PLAYERS, AND THEY
THROW THEM IN ONE SCHOOL AND
THEY INDOCTRINATE THE KIDS.
MY SON IS BRILLIANT.
WRIGHT NOW THEY ARE LOOKING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO INDOCTRINATE
HIM TO MAKE HIM BE ANOTHER PART
OF THE SYSTEM.
I HAVE A CHOIR AT MY SCHOOL.
WRIGHT NOW WE HAVE COME TO A
COMPROMISE.
I AM NOT FINISHED, BECAUSE I
DON'T COMPROMISE.
I CAME TO A COMPROMISE WERE MY
KIDS COME TO MY SCHOOL AFTER
SCHOOL AND THEY LEARN CHOIR.
I SAT THERE WITH MY SON AND HE
SAID WHY DO I NEED TO SING?
I DON'T EVEN GO TO YOUR SCHOOL.
IMAGINE THE 16-YEAR-OLD VERSION
OF THAT GUY.
THE 26-YEAR-OLD VERSION OF THAT
GUY, WHERE THE FATHER DOESN'T
HAVE SAY SO OF WHAT THE KIDS ARE
WATCHING, WHAT THE KIDS ARE
WEARING, WHAT THE KIDS ARE
EATING, WHO THE KIDS ARE HANGING
OUT WITH.
THEY SAID WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO HAVE A
HUMAN UTOPIA, BUT WE ARE LED BY
THE LEAST NOBLE, MOST OF GREEDY
PEOPLE.
THERE IS A SOLUTION THAT CAN
BRING HAPPINESS TO SO MANY MORE
PEOPLE.
I EVEN HAD THIS IDEA ABOUT THE
CONNECTION OF BIG PHARMA TO
FARMS BY HAVING LOCALIZED FARMS.
WITH MORE LOCALIZED FARMS, YOU
CAN USE LESS PESTICIDES.
IF YOU HAVE LESS PESTICIDES,
THEN YOU HAVE LESS DISEASES.
AND HAVE BIG PHARMA INVEST IN
THE LOCAL FARMS AND THEY WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE MORE MONEY.
I AM NOT ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
GO UP AND SAY I WANT TO STOP
ANYBODY FROM MAKING MONEY.
THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE MONEY AND
THE POWERS THAT BE, I AM YOUR
TRUE NIKOLAI TESLA.
AND I AM NOT EVEN A SCIENTIST.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF ELON
MUSK?
DO YOU KNOW HIM?
>> VERY WELL.
>> WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON HIM?
>>> YOU SAID THAT BECAUSE I SAID
TESLA?
>> I DID.
>> EVERYONE SAID ELON HAS
ANSWERS.
I THINK HE'S A GREAT TEAM PLAYER
LIKE I SAID ABOUT WRAY AND
UTOPIA.
IN ROME, THEY WOULD BRING ALL
THE MOST BRILLIANT PEOPLE AND
HAVE THEM SIT DOWN TO THE POINT
WHERE THEIR SEATS HAD A TOILET
IN THEM.
PEOPLE WOULD NOT EVEN GET UP TO
USE THE BATHROOM.
THEY WOULD IDEATE ABOUT WHAT
SOCIETY NEEDED.
THEY WOULD INVENT NEW THINGS AND
THEY PUT IT UP ON THE WALL.
THE HONDA, BEFORE IT WAS A
SCHOOL, IS A DESIGN FIRM.
WHAT I WOULD DO IS PULL TOGETHER
ALL MY FAVORITE THINKERS AND WE
WOULD INVENT.
THAT'S WHY I WAS HAPPY THAT YOU
SAW TWO OF THE INVENTIONS WRIGHT
THERE.
IF I HAD SAID THAT BEFORE YOU
DRINK THE COFFEE AND SOME MIGHT
JOKE AND SAY YOU ARE DRINKING
THE KOOL-AID.
BUT BEFORE YOU DRINK THE COFFEE
AND BEFORE YOU SAW THE 3-D PRINT
BOOM.
A ZERO WASTE 3-D PRINTED BOOT.
IF I SAID NIKOLAI TESLA YOU
WOULD PROBABLY STRUGGLED THAT
OFF.
I THINK IT'S INSANE FOR AN
ADMINISTRATION TO NOT USE A
TALENT LIKE ELON MUSK MORE.
I WILL EVENTUALLY BE PRESIDENT
IN MY LIFETIME.
BUT IF I WAS IN OFFICE RIGHT
NOW, I WOULD BE CALLING ELON
EVERY DAY.
I WOULD HAVE HIM SLEEP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I WOULD SAY HOW DO WE USE OUR
PLATFORM AS THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
DOSE THAT'S A FREUDIAN SLIP.
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD TO SHOW THE REST OF
THE WORLD HOW TO LIVE A
SIMPLIFIED LIFE.
BUT OUR COUNTRY IS UNDER ATTACK
AND MEDIA AND INDUSTRIES OUTSIDE
OF OUR COUNTRY ARE DOING
ANYTHING TO KEEP IT AS IT WAS.
EVERYONE IS JUST AFRAID.
GOD IS LOVE.
I UNDERSTAND I COME OFF SCARY
SOMETIMES BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
PROTECT MY KIDS, I'M GOING TO
PROTECT MY REPUTATION.
I'M GOING TO PROTECT MY BRANDS.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE TO
PULL THE GUNS OUT AND PULLED THE
SWORDS OUT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE RIGHTEOUS
INDIGNATION AS UNCHRISTIAN FOR
EVERYONE THAT EVER SAID I CANNOT
GET MAD BECAUSE I'M A CHRISTIAN
KIRK AS A QUESTION?
YEAH.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
CAN.
AND BE SO SUCCESSFUL AND
INFLUENTIAL IN THE MUSIC
BUSINESS AND FASHION INDUSTRY,
THE TWO MOST LIBERAL BUSINESSES
IN THE WORLD AS A PRO-LIFE
BADGE.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> I ALWAYS THINK THAT WHENEVER
GOD ALLOWS A BRILLIANT IDEA TO
CHANNEL THROUGH ME AND ALLOWS ME
TO SOMEHOW TAKE CREDIT FOR IT, I
ALWAYS SNICKER AT THE FACT THAT
WITH LIBERALS THEIR MAIN TOOL
THAT THEY USE ARTIST AND
INFLUENCERS.
BUT THEN GOD HAS THE NUMBER ONE
ARTIST AND NUMBER ONE INFLUENCER
AS A CONSERVATIVE.
I ALWAYS CHUCKLE AT THAT.
EVERY TIME I COME UP WITH
SOMETHING BRILLIANT I SAY CAN
YOU IMAGINE IF THEY COULD HAVE
INDOCTRINATED BY E?
THE WORLD COULD HAVE TOTALLY
BEEN TOTALLY RAN INTO THE [
BLEEP ] WHOLE.
THERE ARE TIMES THAT THE DEVIL
HAD ONE.
BUT FOR ME TO HAVE GONE FROM
JESUS WALKS TO YOUR SUCH A [
BLEEP ] , I LOVE IT.
THAT'S THE DEVIATION FROM THE
PATH.
EVERY TIME I LOVE THAT QUESTION,
IT TICKLES ME.
THE VERY THING THAT LIBERALS USE
THE MOST OF, THEY DON'T HAVE THE
BEST PERSON AT IT.
>> DO YOU TALK TO OTHER PEOPLE
IN YOUR BUSINESS WHO ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN MUSIC, INDUSTRY
AND FASHION BUSINESS WHO
SECRETLY AGREE WITH YOU?
>> YEAH, THERE IS A LOT OF
FASHION PEOPLE.
TOMMY HILFIGER LOVED TRUNK.
LET ME SEE.
I'VE GOT TO THINK OF ALL THE
OTHER TRUMP-I'M NOT EVEN GOING
TO USE THE TERM TRUMP SUPPORTER.
WHY DON'T PEOPLE SAY HILLARY
SUPPORTER OR BIDEN SUPPORTER?
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE IN MY BUSINESS
WHO LOVE TRUMP?
BUSINESSMAN.
PEOPLE WHO LOVE MONEY.
PEOPLE WHO LIKE BEING SUCCESSF